hey 42 here film producer Jeffrey
Katzenberg was responsible for reviving
Walt Disney Studios by producing some of
their biggest hits including The Lion
King The Little Mermaid Beauty and the
Beast and Aladdin after which he
requested a promotion but he was instead
abruptly fired
he swore revenge on the Disney
Corporation and founded DreamWorks
Studios welcome to RIF the reason that
artificial banana flavorings taste so
different to actual banana is because
artificial banana flavorings are based
on a type of banana called gross
Michelle bananas that were wiped out by
a plague in the 1950s on an island off
the southwest coast of Australia named
Middle Island there is a large lake that
has a bright pink bubblegum color called
Lake Hillier a mantis shrimp can swing
its claws so fast that it boils the
water around it and creates a flash of
light Australia has over 10,000 beaches
you could visit a brand new beach every
day for over 27 years to determine if a
female is suitable for mating a male
giraffe will approach the female and rub
up against her backside until she pees
the male then tastes the urine to
determine whether she's in heat or not
what's even more disturbing is that
scientists thought it necessary to give
this bizarre ritual a name it's called
the Fleming sequence Nintendo was
originally a trading card company there
is an uninhabited island in the Bahamas
known as Pig Beach which is populated
entirely by swimming pigs a scientist at
a computer program a computer chip using
natural selection the outcome was an
extremely efficient chip the inner
workings of which were too complex from
a human to understand a group of women
called the nine nanos kept a secret for
decades that not even their husbands
knew about for 30 years they met at 4:00
a.m. and anonymously paid bills and
brought clothes for people
need each care package included a
homemade pound cake and a note with red
somebody loves you approximately 1
million euros are thrown into Rome's
trevi fountain each year the money is
used to subsidize a supermarket for
those in need as a teenager george RR
martin was the first-ever person to buy
a ticket for the first ever comic-con
held in new york city in 1964 when we
breathe through our nose we inhale more
air from one nostril Nani over but they
swap around every 15 minutes the mayor
of the Alaskan town of talkeetna is a
cat called stops this faithful ball of
fur has been mayor of the town since
1997 in 2013 in China scientists managed
to grow a human tooth using nothing but
stem cells taken from Yuri in 1969 a
musician named Jim Sullivan recorded an
album called UFO which included unusual
lyrics about leaving his family and
being abducted by aliens
Sullivan disappeared six years later
without a trace the only evidence was
his abandoned car found on a desert road
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you